it's Senate Judiciary Committee hearing
day for Christine Blasi Ford one of
Brett Kavanaugh as accusers and Brett
Kavanaugh will testify as well so that's
all that matters today I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
oh yes we will go wall-to-wall with all
of the latest suffice it to say this is
not going well for Republicans I will
explain why for all the reasons it is
not going well also what the actual
hearings should have been designed to do
and what they actually were not designed
to do we'll get to all of that in just
one second first if it feels like can
you drink you're not alone okay the
reality is that on a daily like that's
pretty much all of us especially in this
business need a drink and if you
actually would like a drink of something
good you should go out and check out our
friends over at wink wink makes it easy
to discover great wines well we've taken
a little bit of time to bring ourselves
out from the New Year if you want to you
know go back to drinking now's the time
to do it go check it out with wink wink
swine experts electrons match to your
taste personalized for you shipped right
to your door starting just 13 bucks a
bottle there's nothing like coming home
to a bottle of delicious wink wine
selected just for you and they they have
this thing called the palate profile
quiz and ask you simple questions like
do you like blueberries or how do you
take your coffee and then they give you
wine recommendations based on that folks
around the offices have have had taste
tests of the wine and they loved it
I mean so much so that they are not
usable the rest of the day after these
taste tests but you can go check out
wink calm right now it's try wink calm
slash Ben T ry winc comm slash Ben and
when you use that slash Ben you get $20
off your first shipment which is a
pretty solid deal try blink comm slash
Ben wing sends wines curated to your
taste each month there are new delicious
wines there's no membership fees you can
skip any month you can cancel anytime
and shipping is covered so pretty solids
you'll go check it out right now
tri wink comm slash Ben for $20 off okay
well today is of course the big hearing
day and today is the day in which the
Senate Judiciary Committee after at long
last interviewed kristinb lazy Ford who
is the first accuser against Brett
Kavanaugh now to stop for just a second
before we actually get into the
accusations that kristinb lazy Ford made
we should recognize that there been a
number of allegations have been made and
I want to go through them this is the
one that matters kristinb lazy Fords is
the one that matters because it is the
most credible and it's the most credible
because it is the one that that rings
the truest there's still questions about
it and this is the problem for
Republicans from the very outset it was
unclear what Republicans were attempting
to argue about these allegations were
they arguing that kristinb lazy Ford was
lying I for one never argued that
kristinb lazy Ford was lying I always
believed that she sort of believed what
she believed she'd come forward with
these allegations before
at Cavanaugh was even selected for the
Supreme Court when he was just on the
shortlist and there's evidence that she
had talked about it back in 2012 I was
never somebody who suggested a christine
Blasi Ford was lying I questioned
whether her memories might not have been
correct because memories change over 30
years I questioned whether more
importantly the evidence was sufficient
to knock Brett Kavanaugh out and this
was always the big question the big
question to me was is an allegation
alone no matter how credible without any
corroborating evidence whatsoever is
that enough to stop a nomination that's
really the question because no matter
how credible witness is it's going to be
he said she said if they're the only
people in the room and in this
particular case christine Blasi Ford had
suggested there were other people at a
party when she was 15 and Brett
Kavanaugh was 17 she says that at that
party Cavanaugh and his friend Mark
judge forced her into a room turned up
the music and Cavanaugh forced her onto
a bed where he attempted to take off her
clothes and then placed his hand over
her mouth when she tried to scream
there's no other witness that has
verified this count mark judge has
denied it I think he should be
subpoenaed but mark judge denied it
Brett Kavanaugh denied it she says there
were other people at the party we'll get
into her specific allegations in a
moment including one of her close
friends who has denied that she was at
any party where's Brett Kavanaugh so
there is no corroborating evidence we
don't know date we don't know location
we don't know time we don't know how she
got there
so even if she is telling the absolute
truth there is no way to actually
corroborate any of her story the reason
that matters is because this was
happening in a quasi public setting
there should be some corroborating
detail if you look at situations
involving Bill Cosby or Harvey Weinstein
there are ways that you can corroborate
at least that people are telling the
story at the time as I mentioned on the
show when I was in high school I I've
said 15 but I believe I was actually 13
or 14 because it was my sophomore year
of high school when I was in high school
I was abused by some kids in my class I
remember where it was I remember who the
kids were and I should be able to lock
down the date if I just look at a
yearbook or look back at a calendar and
I can find people to corroborate the
story
there's no corroborating evidence here
and Blasi Ford has been unable to really
corroborate any of that now does that
mean she's lying no it doesn't mean
she's lying it doesn't mean she's lying
at all and so what this comes down to is
is the allegation itself enough if you
believe the allegation itself is enough
all that mattered today from the hearing
is that Blasi Ford was emotional when
she spoke about this because she
obviously experienced a trauma and
Experian
Payne both of which I believe by the way
I believe that she did experience some
trauma and she is experiencing pain I
don't doubt any of that but the question
becomes without any other corroborating
evidence is that enough and so that's
just made today basically a sort of
public assessment of her performance was
her performance credible was her
performance believable was her
performance emotional which is kind of
gross I mean that is kind of gross the
fact that the public question was going
to come down to how well could this
alleged attempted rape victim tell her
story because in that sense if she had
been more robotic would we not have
believed her if she'd come off a little
bit less collected would we not have
believed her if she had not come across
emotional would we not have believed her
and those are uncomfortable questions
but that's why Republicans never should
have gotten into this line of
questioning in the first place the
question all we should have been listen
even if we believe your story
there's no corroborating evidence and we
have a denial on the other side that
means that there is some burden of proof
to come forward with some form of
corroborating evidence and he just
haven't supplied that because
Republicans didn't do that the hearing
turned into his christine Blasi Ford a
credible witness
is she a believable witness and what
you'll see is a lot of folks on the
right saying she's not credible she's
not believable because her memory was
skewed in other areas but her contention
and I think it's not a completely unfair
contention is well I may not have
remembered the actual date of this
happening but I certainly remember the
feeling and being pushed down on a bed
having a guy jump on top of me put his
hand over her mouth and I remember his
face that's not that's not in an
incredible suggestion it's not not
incredible and that's that's relatively
credible when bad things happen in your
life you remember the specific bad thing
that happened in your life you don't
necessarily remember well the
surrounding circumstances the problem is
there's no way for us to adjudicate
whether her memory is faulty or not
because there's no corroborating
evidence okay so that's Christine Blasi
Ford I wanted to mention these other
allegations to demonstrate that not
every allegation necessarily ought to be
believed just on the basis of the
allegation so Debra Martinez I've said
in a piece in The New Yorker earlier
this week on Sunday The New Yorker
reported that Martinez had alleged that
Kavanagh thrust his penis in her face at
a frat party at which he was drinking
while he was at Yale University but the
New Yorker piece is extraordinarily weak
according to the publication she was
hesitant to speak publicly because quote
her memories contained gaps
because she had been drinking at the
time of the alleged incident and she was
quote-unquote reluctant to characterize
Cavanaugh's role in the alleged incident
with certainty so even she says that she
didn't know what happened this
particular accuser only after and the
direct quote from The New Yorker six
days of carefully assessing her memories
and consulting with her attorneys that
she decided to come forward no
corroborating witnesses have come
forward then yesterday there's an
accusation made by Julie sweat Nick
who's a woman brought forward by Michael
avenatti the lawyer for stormy Daniels
and 2020 Democratic candidate for
president and according to her sworn
declaration she saw Kavanaugh get drunk
in high school and then groped girls
against their will as well as spiking
punch with quaaludes and alcohol and
participating in a gang rape line at
multiple parties that's her description
sweat Nick says she went to
approximately ten parties at which such
events took place
so his Debora Ramirez not Martinez sweat
Nick says she went to ten parties at
which such activities took place
she says she was the victim of such a
gang rape but is unclear in her
declaration whether Kavanagh
participated a vinod he refuses to
answer simple questions on her behalf he
has not made her available to testify
she says there are other witnesses but
none have come forward so again in
accusation with no corroborating
evidence the New York Times put a kindly
quote none of Miss sweat Nick's claims
could be independently corroborated by
the New York Times and her lawyer
Michael avenatti declines make her
available for an interview and then late
on Wednesday afternoon a fourth
allegation came for this was from NBC
News reporting that the Senate Judiciary
Committee was inquiring about another
allegation of misconduct they reported
that an anonymous woman said that her
daughter's friend was physically
assaulted by Kavanagh in a Washington DC
area bar while he was drunk she said
when they left the bar under the
influence of alcohol they were all
shocked when Kavanagh shoved her friend
up against the wall very aggressively
and sexually there were at least four
witnesses including my daughter the
daughter has not come forward the woman
has not come forward none of the
witnesses have come forward
so another uncorroborated in this case
anonymous allegation made against Brett
Kavanaugh now maybe Kavanagh did some of
this maybe he did none of this we don't
know any of those questions what is
certainly true is that there is not a
court of law
in the United States civil or criminal
that would either convict or punish
based on just the allegations alone
there's no way to do that so is it in a
country where there is due process it
seems to me that an allegation alone
should not be enough to support the
destruction
of a man's life and a man's career no
matter how credible the person telling
the story and this is what Republicans
failed to say in the lead up to this
hearing instead the narrative was put
out there that maybe she was lying or
maybe she was politically motivated but
that was never the question we live in a
system where due process actually
matters and that due process doesn't
necessarily apply in the court of public
opinion but if we're gonna be
intellectually honest about how we
actually assess situations we have to
have something beyond a mere allegation
maybe it's that there are multiple
allegations and all the allegations have
similar elements is in the Bill Cosby or
Harvey Weinstein cases maybe it's that
there's corroborating evidence that some
of this stuff happened as with Roy Moore
but an allegation alone it seems to me
is really weak sauce and if that had
been the case nothing in the hearing
with Christine Blasi formed have changed
anything today nothing would have
changed anything because not only did
she not provide any corroborating
evidence what she actually showed is
that the only memory she seems to hold
clearly is the actual incident itself
with Cavanaugh everything else her
memory seems particularly hazy and again
that doesn't answer whether this
happened or not and it doesn't even
answer whether she is correctly
remembering what happened with Cavanaugh
or not what it is suggesting is that
memory itself is variable and not only
that it suggests that without any other
corroborating evidence which he actually
weakened today wrenchy weakens the
possibility of corroborating evidence
today should not strengthen the
nothing she said today brought
additional evidence to the table it was
just her telling her story in her words
so you have to ask yourself what changed
between yesterday and today
last night she put forward her actual
statement her statement was written it
was very similar to what she had told
the newspapers it's very similar to what
she had said in a letter to Diane
Feinstein and representative in
California named and eschew none of that
changed the only thing that changed is
that we actually put a face to the
accusation if that's the case then what
we really had today was an emotional
appeal and listen I felt the emotional
appeal to because it's hard not to watch
a woman who's experiencing pain that she
attributes to a dire trauma right to an
incident that any of us would have
responded with fury to and say okay well
that's that's now more credible but is
it more credible because she said it out
loud is it more as opposed to credible
doesn't provide any level of objective
verification of the events she speaks of
because she set it out loud I don't
think so
I don't think so and if it does you have
to ask yourself what exactly changed
what exactly changed now this was a loss
for Republicans and I'll explain why it
was a loss for Republicans in just a
second but first let's talk about your
sleep quality there's nobody on the
planet like you so why would you buy a
generic mattress built for anyone else
Hewlett sleep has built a sleep quiz
that takes two minutes to complete they
use the answers to match your body type
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress whether you're a side sleeper
or a hot sleeper whether you like a
plush or a firm bed with helix there's
no more guessing at no more confusion
just go to helix sleep calm /ban take
their two minutes sleep quiz and they
will match you to a mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your life
I've taken the sleep quiz with my wife
we order the mattress it came in the
mail you unwrap it it's just inflates in
front of you pop it on the bed friend
you're good to go I got one for my
sister for a wedding because the
mattresses are just that comfortable
couples can even have each side tailored
for your particular sleep preferences
they have a 10-year warranty and you get
to try it out for a hundred nights risk
freeze there really is nothing to lose
right now helix is offering up to 125
bucks off all mattress orders get up to
125 bucks off at helix sleep calm slash
Ben that's helix sleep calm slash Ben
for 125 dollars off your mattress order
again helix sleep calm slash Ben go
check it out their mattresses are
supremely comfortable and again tailored
specifically to use so you're getting a
tailored mattress made just for you
helix sleep calm slash been used the
slash pen to let them know we sent you
and get a hundred and twenty five bucks
off your mattress order okay so back to
what this set up for the hearing what
Democrats wanted out of the hearing was
something very simple a binary she's
lying or she's not lying
that was the binary and Democrats said
we believe her she's not lying and what
they're hoping to do by that is suggest
that anyone who didn't believe her was
there for a sexist and doesn't believe
doesn't believe women who are credible
but that really wasn't the question
again the question for this hearing
should have been even if you believe she
is not lying our allegations without any
corroborating evidence whatsoever none
zero zilch any corroborating evidence
are those allegations enough to finish a
guy's career that's how Republicans
should have played this they should have
said we don't know whether to believe
her or not
we may find her credible but we can't
have a standard of evidence in this
country where people are denied a career
and a life based on unverifiable and
unverified allegations from a vague time
in the past where there should be public
witnesses in there are not
that's what Republicans should have been
arguing instead they allowed Democrats
to turn this into is she believable at
her she's not and the answer is yeah
she's believable there's nothing about
her that suggests that she's not
believable like listen to her tell her
story so here is four she told her story
and what you'll see is that Republicans
had appointed a woman named Mitchell to
who's a prosecutor to question her and
and this woman basically went after the
fact that Blasi Ford's memory has lots
of holes in different places but Blasi
for basically defeats all of those
attempts with a simple statement which
is I may not remember everything else in
my life but I remember that time the guy
jumped on top of me put his hand on my
mouth and tried to rape me right that's
all she had to say
it takes everything else off the table
if Republicans had said before that
listen it sounds like what happened to
you was awful but we have a guy over
here who denies it you've provided no
other evidence and then they'd asked her
okay well you can't provide any other
evidence can you help us can you help us
establish another chain of evidence
if Republicans had done that then maybe
this turns into something else instead
what it turned into is we're supposed to
doubt her because of various questions
about her her history of flying or were
supposed to doubt her because she has
not been completely forthcoming about
her polygraph or stuff like that they're
trying to kind of suggest that she is
not inherently believable again it's
hard to claim that an attempted rape
account is false because she fibbed
about her dislike for flying if in fact
she flipped about her dislike for flying
we'll get into all that in just a second
here is what Ford talked about today I
am here today not because I want to be I
am terrified I am here because I believe
it is my civic duty to tell you what
happened to me well Brett Cavanaugh and
I were in high school okay so she
obviously is is pretty collected here
and then she goes on to say that she
believed that Cavanaugh was going to
rape her I was pushed onto the bed and
Brett got on top of me he began running
his hands over my body and grinding into
me
I yelled hoping that someone downstairs
might hear me and I tried to get away
from him but his weight was heavy
Brett groped me and tried to take off my
clothes
he had a hard time because he was very
inebriated and because I was wearing a
one-piece bathing suit underneath my
clothing I believed he was going to rape
me okay so obviously this is very
affecting testimony there's no not to
watch this and feel enormous sympathy
for the person who's telling the story
doesn't give you any corroborating
detail no right and that's why how you
frame the question matters an awful lot
and this is why when when Ford actually
got to being asked okay could you have
mistaken Brett Kavanaugh for somebody
else and she answered it was very bad
for Republicans here are the two clips
that really made the most they really
made the most hash of Cavanaugh here is
it clip 20 this is Ford talking about
how she fully remembers all of this
happening how are you so sure that it
was he the same way that I'm sure that
I'm talking to you right now is just
basic memory functions and also just the
level of norepinephrine and epinephrine
in the brain that sort of as you know
encodes that neurotransmitter encodes
memories into the hippocampus and so the
trauma related experience then is kind
of locked there whereas other details
kind of drift so what you were telling
us is this could not be a case of
mistaken identity absolutely not I can't
guarantee that there weren't a few other
people there but they are not in in my
purview of my memory would it be fair to
say there were at least four others yes
okay okay so there's where she sort of
changed her story but again it doesn't
matter because the Republicans had not
established what exactly they were
trying to do there and this was part of
the problem at the format so you see
blazing Ford said listen it's imprinted
on my memory that somebody tried to rape
me and then she says all the other
details were hazy and then when
Republicans the the woman questioning is
Rachel Mitchell who is this Republican
Special Counsel when she pushes back and
she says okay well what about the fact
that you've now changed her story
multiple times on how many people were
at the party
blazing Ford says right I don't remember
that stuff so well because that's not
when I was being raped right so she'd
preempted the attack by essentially
saying this is the only thing that I can
remember really well and this is this is
the problem and this was underscored by
the next thing she said where she was
asked specifically about what she
remembers the most and this this is the
quote that's gonna be played a thousand
times tonight on on cable news indelible
in the hippocampus is the laughter the
laughte the uproarious laughter between
the two and they're having fun at my
expense in other words the object of the
laughter I was you know underneath one
of them that while the two left two
front two friends having a really good
time with one another okay so this
opened a bunch of questions for
Republicans none of which they were
willing to take right they could have
called mark judge to rebut that's the
guy who she claims is in the room with
Kavanagh he's already said under oath
that he was not there for any of this
and he doesn't know what any of this was
but it would have been worthwhile to
question him but here's the point what
Republicans did with this hearing was a
huge mistake because what they did is
they basically brought in a special
counsel to talk to this won't this
accuser and then they split it up they
had her ask a question for five minutes
and then they let Democrats grandstand
for five minutes and so there was never
any line of continuity trying to
establish what it was they were trying
to establish what should have happened
is you got Mitchell out there says
listen whether we believe your story or
not and you seem like a credible very
nice person who suffered an awful trauma
we need to try and find some detail we
can corroborate here so that we can move
forward with the seriousness of the
allegations and so now I'm going to ask
you a series of questions that are
designed to elicit just that sort of
corroboration and then at the end you
say okay well if we couldn't find
corroboration we can't find
corroboration instead Republicans
started asking questions that went to
flaws in her memory but that don't
undermine her central case meanwhile
Democrats asked questions like how did
it feel when a guy was trying to rape
you who do you think is gonna win that
PR battle because that's what this has
become right I mean this is a PR battle
this is not a question as to the truth
or falsity of the allegations
unfortunately Democrats are not
interested in that Republicans don't
seem particularly interested in that
nobody's really interested in the truth
or falsity
because there's no way to find that out
so this has become a political tool
we'll get to more of this in just one
second but first let's talk about making
your company better well the best way to
make our company better is to head over
to zipper
cruder calm you don't want the worst
applications coming in you don't want to
have to post out a thousand job sites
instead go to zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire zip recruiter doesn't wait
for candidates to find you zip recruiter
finds them for you it has powerful
matching technology it scans thousands
of resumes identifies people with the
right skills education and experience
for your job and actively invites them
to apply so you get qualified candidates
fast no more sorting through the wrong
resumes no more waiting for the right
candidates to apply it's no wonder zip
recruiter is rated number one by
employers in the United States and right
now my listeners can try zip recruiter
for free at this exclusive web address
zip recruiter comm slash daily wire at
zip recruiter comm slash daily Wire Dai
ly wir a zipper quarter comm slash daily
wires you can try it for free upgrade
the members of your staff I mean if
somebody does a bad job today they might
be out on the street I'm not gonna
mention any names like Alex I won't
mention any names like that and say that
maybe we'll be replacing him with daily
wire later on
Alex silence back there listen zip
recruiter is the way that you can make
your company better go check it out
right now zip recruiters comm slash
daily wire zip recruiter is indeed the
smartest way to hire which is why we use
it here at daily wire go check it out
right now
that powerful matching technology can
make your company a hell of a lot better
okay so the as I say the way that this
was formatted for Republicans was bad
because if they had been trying to
establish that there were no
corroborating details and if they'd been
trying also to establish the Democrats
manipulated the process there are ways
to do that cuz the truth is there were
holes in Ford's testimony she was asked
specifically for example what year did
this take place because earlier she had
said it took place sometime when I was
in high school then she had narrowed it
down to the specific summer and she
never really gave an excuse as to why
that happened
she was specifically asked about whether
she gave her psychiatrists records to
the Washington Post for example because
the first account that she had told of
this story to someone not her husband
was to her psychiatrist
this sort of locked it into a timeline
back in 2012 she's claimed medical
privilege on those on those records she
has not handed them over to the the
actual Republicans on the Senate
Judiciary Committee which would kind of
be important because you'd want to see
if there are discrepancies in her
accounts of the events she hasn't handed
those over but she did hand them to the
Washington Post
how do we know she handed them to the
we know she handed them to the
Washington Post because it said so in
the Washington Post story The Washington
Post story explicitly said that she gave
her psychiatrist records to the
Washington Post but when she was asked
about it suddenly she didn't remember
which does raise questions about the
capacity of her memory for example a
full or partial set of those marriage
therapy records to the Washington Post I
don't remember I remember summarizing
for her what they said so I'm not quite
sure if I actually gave her the record
okay so obviously she didn't give them
the record is she miss remembering you
don't know right
speaking of miss remembering we were
told last week that Christine Blasi Ford
could not show up on Monday for a
hearing because Christine Blasi Ford had
a fear of flying this was a serious
question because in the past week there
been a bunch of nut more unverified
allegations that have come forward that
seemed timed by Democrats I mean it's
just a giant coincidence that all these
allegations come forward from Monday
through Thursday and they all start
breaking in the news this week
well Blasi Ford's original claim or at
least the claim of her lawyers is that
she couldn't show up on Monday because
number one shouldn't want to be
questioned on that side of the country
and number two she had a fear of flying
well it turns out that her fear of
flying has not prohibited her prohibited
her soom she has a fear of flying but it
hasn't stopped her from flying in what
she considers important circumstances
circumstances ranging from surf trips to
visiting her family on the East Coast
every year to coming in August to
Maryland to I think to Delaware to to
take a polygraph test so in other words
she flies an awful lot and yet somehow
she couldn't fly but then she did fly to
get to this hearing she didn't take a
car across the country she flew across
the country well that raises questions
about how Democrats have manipulated the
timeline here and the person who's been
done the most disservice by the
Democrats is Blasi Ford
she's been under tremendous disservice
because let's say that she's telling the
absolute 100% truth
it looks manipulative no matter how this
was played because Democrats weren't in
fact manipulating the process Dianne
Feinstein's did not come forward with
the allegations for eight weeks and
Feinstein's did not release it to the
FBI Dianne Feinstein's did not question
Cavanaugh about it either in public or
in private the Democrats turned down a
private hearing for Ford right the
Republicans said you wanna do this
behind closed doors let's do it there
nope the Republicans said what if we
send our representatives to you and
question
you out west nope instead they said she
has to come East but she can't fly but
then she turned out to fly rachel
mitchell points this out that was
certainly what I was hoping was to avoid
having to get on an airplane but I
eventually was able to get up the
gumption with the help of some friends
and get on the plane when you were here
in the middle mid-atlantic area back in
August end of July August how did you
get here
also by airplane I come here once the
year during this summer to visit my
family in fact you fly fairly frequently
for your hobbies and your you've had to
fly for your work is that true correct
unfortunately so folks on the Left were
mocking this like oh well who cares
about her flight well it goes to the
Democratic manipulation of the process
because again we were told the Democrats
just wanted to get down to facts but it
turns out they were delaying the
timeline for obviously political reasons
all of which still does not go to the
key point of this case and I get back to
the key point of this case over and over
again because I think it really is
important not just for this nomination
which is I'll explain what I think is
gonna happen with it in just a second
but it's also important because of
what's going to happen with future
nominations is it enough to have a
credible allegation of something bad
happening uncorroborated by uh fact of
fact ok there's no corroborating fact
here none none and this is it's not just
me saying this by the way Jake Tapper
even made this point on CNN last night
that there's no real corroborating
evidence for any of this because it
turns out there's no corroborating
evidence for any of this by not setting
the standard Republicans really did
Cavanagh a disservice and did themselves
a serious to service Democrats are
saying that Cavanaugh obviously should
withdraw this in and of itself is sort
of self-defeating I'm not sure why they
think that he should like they're saying
he should withdraw why not just call for
there to be a vote right why don't why
not just put Republicans on the record
it seems to me that if Democrats really
wanted to put Republicans feet to the
fire they would say no he shouldn't
withdraw make Republicans say whether
they believe her or not that would be
the smart political move
I don't think President Trump is
actually going to pull the nomination
the reason I don't think Trump is going
to pull the nomination is because
president Trump tends to believe that
accusations by women are very often
he feels he's been victimized by such
accusations in some cases
he certainly has not been victimized by
some accusations President Trump did a
presser yesterday and here's what he had
to say about the situation this of
course was before the hearing but I've
had a lot of false charges made against
me really false charges I know friends
that have had false charges people want
Fame they want money they want whatever
so when I see it I view it differently
than somebody sitting home watching
television where they say Oh judge Cavan
or this or that so when you say does it
affect me in terms of my thinking with
respect to judge Kavanagh absolutely
because I've had it many times okay the
reason this is a giant fail is because
this is president from falling directly
into the trap that Democrats have set
for him which is President Trump saying
I've been accused falsely a lot of times
therefore Cavanaugh has been accused
falsely a lot of times except that there
are a lot of allegations of President
Trump engaging in really bad behavior
with women sexually abusive behavior
with women and president Trump was
caught on tape lest we forget saying he
grabs women by the genitals not the same
thing as Brett Kavanaugh who maintains
his complete innocence in all of this
but this does set the mindset for the
president to not believe any of this he
doesn't believe it about himself and he
also like I think that if you give
President Trump a lie-detector test a
polygraph really only detects stress it
really detects whether you think you are
lying
it doesn't detect whether you are
telling the truth but it's sex whether
you might think you're lying and
supposedly raises stress levels not
particularly scientific if you hooked
President Trump up to a lie detector to
it to a polygraph machine my guess is
that everything President Trump says
would always pass the lie-detector test
because he actually believes all the
stuff that he says the problem is that
he is now set it up is Ford lying or is
she not well what this means is I don't
think that Trump pulls Cavanaugh's
nomination I think Trump leaves
Cavanaugh's nomination no matter what
happens and Kavanagh I can't imagine is
gonna be able to row but the testimony
right no matter how much sympathy he
shows you can't rebut the testimony of a
woman who claims that you were lying on
top of her trying to rape her pretty
difficult to rebut that I don't think
Trump polls the nomination I think
instead what happens is probably that
Lisa Murkowski of Alaska and Susan
Collins of Maine probably vote against
Cavanaugh's nomination that kills the
nomination Trump blames squish
Republicans for finishing Kavanagh his
bass is happy because he didn't pull the
nomination any fights and by the way I
don't think he should pull the
nomination because again I think there
should be a standard of corroborated of
evidence that is presented if we're
gonna start pulling nominations but I
don't think Trump pulls the nomination I
think he lets this thing go down and
flaming defeat I think he nominates Amy
Kony Barrett and then Democrats get what
they want which is a referendum in
November on whether Republicans should
control the next Supreme Court seat if
Republicans do not have a majority in
November of the Senate there will be
eight people on the Supreme Court from
here until 2021 Democrats are not going
to allow President Trump to fill the
seat that's what this has always been
about this is always for Democrats and
I've got enough for Ford for Democrats
this has always been about political
manipulation for the press it's been
about political manipulation as well
there are too many members of the press
who have treated allegations as verified
facts there are too many members of the
press who have treated evidence-free
allegations as absolutely justified
we're gonna get to all of that in just a
second but first let's talk about your
comfort with your underwear you may know
that Tommy John as the creator's are the
most comfortable underwear on the planet
for men and women but little did you
know they've been working on
revolutionizing comfort for men's dress
shirts as well after six years in 200
different wear tested prototypes Tommy
John has perfected the state tucked
dress shirt is truly unlike anything
guys have ever experienced the state
tuck dress shirt it's fantastic I wear
button-down shirts every day and I can
tell you Tommy John shirts just great
why because these are created to end the
constant tuck of war men have endured
for years with their dress shirts get it
it's a tug of war because you're tucking
it in with invisi grapes snap technology
you won't have to deal with any
billowing or bunching the 360-degree
underarm stretch panel allows for full
range of motion stretch twists even put
luggage on an airplane without
restriction or untucking upgrade today
with Tommy John no adjustment needed go
to Tommy John comm / Shapiro - save 20%
on your first order plus free shipping
and free returns on all dress shirt
purchases that is Tommy John comm /
Shapiro for 20% off all the products are
just fantastic by the way not just the
dress shirts everything is great that
their underwear is supremely comfortable
it hasn't no wedgie guarantee which I
could have used in high school go check
it out right now Tommy John comm /
apparel for 20% off again that's Tommy
John dot-com / apparel for 20% off and
let them know that we sent you alright
so I do want to get into the press's
behavior and democratic behavior today
at the hearings because again
I'm not gonna say that kristinb lazy
Ford is a political actor I am going to
say the Democrats and the media have
acted in entirely political fashion
surrounding the Kavanagh accusations
we'll get to that in just a second for
that you have to go over to Daily wire
and subscribe for $9.99 a month you can
get a subscription to daily wear when
you do you get the rest of the show live
you get the rest of the Andrew Klavan
show live that's the Michael notional
live the rest of them the Matt Walsh
show live I don't know I'd want I know
why you want a nolza show but I mean if
that's the thing you want you can still
get it $9.99 a month gets you all of
those things plus for $99 a year you get
this leftist Cheers hot or cold tumblr
notice it says leftist years now liberal
tears liberals are just people who
disagree on politics leftists are people
who try to shut me down from speaking at
USC but go check it out right now 99
dollars cheaper than the monthly
subscription and you get this the very
greatest in beverage vessels it does
give you the power of invisibility I
have heard I can't make that claim with
full veracity but I have heard also
eternal life right if Indiana Jones had
just chosen the leftist here's hot or
cold tumblr if that other guy in Indiana
Jones in the Holy Grail had chosen that
at the end of the movie his face
wouldn't have melted off and withered go
check it out right now for $99 a year
also please subscribe to us at YouTube
or iTunes we have a Sunday special this
week feature in camera and kasky someone
with whom I disagree a lot on politics
but a 17 year old kid who's at Parkland
and and really I think is attempting to
search for a better politics so good for
him you know you can listen to that
interview this week go check it out
right now we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
so the the treatment of the Democrats is
really what's been egregious in all of
this
Republicans have basically said we will
do whatever Ford wants in terms of
having her here we are willing to hear
allegations I will say that I think
Republicans should have subpoenaed Marc
judge I don't understand why they didn't
subpoena Marc judge if they think that
they are trying to get down to the fact
but Democrats have been political with
this since the beginning Dianne
Feinstein was political with this since
the beginning the media have been
political about this too
why well look at the way that they
treated at least many in the media not
everyone in the media look at how many
in the media treated the Michael
avenatti allegations from yesterday so
an allegation comes forward a woman
claims that Brett Kavanaugh was part of
a gang rape gang back in high school she
said there were tons of witnesses not a
single witness comes forward she claims
that she went to ten separate parties at
which there were these gang rapes and
drugging of women which does beg the
question as to why would you go back I
mean when's the last time you went to a
party you saw a gang rape line and
people drugging the punch and you're
like you know what there's one of these
next week I'm coming back I got to see
whether it just goes differently next
time and then do that 10 times it turns
out by the way that the woman who makes
the accusation was three years older
than Brett Kavanaugh graduate in 1980
which suggests that she was actually a
college woman like a full-grown woman
going to high school parties watching
gang rape lines happen and then saying
nothing which is weird in and of itself
but the way that many in the media treat
this was a massive headline it was
repeated over and over and over without
a lot of these questions being asked I
will point out one person who did ask
the question CNN's Jake Tapper did grill
Michael avenatti on this in avenatti
obviously had no answers that by the way
did not stop Dianne Feinstein from today
in the hearing suggesting that there are
three separate credible allegations
against Cavanaugh which there are not
there's one seriously credible
allegation against Cavanaugh in my
opinion that's Ford even that has no
corroborating evidence the other two
from Debra Ramirez and and from the the
sweat neck I think that those are
significantly less credible the least
credible is sweat Nick for precisely the
reasons Jake Tapper is about to show you
I mean just to say he was present is is
a really egregious lack of specificity
when you're talking about charges this
horrific and I'm not saying that I don't
believe them I'm just saying what
exactly are you saying
or is she saying
that he did Jake I disagree completely
with what you just said let me be clear
about something this is not my
declaration these are statements by my
clients
these are her statement about what
happened okay well that doesn't help at
all and tapper of course is exactly
right about all of this
I should note on mark judge Republicans
did interview mark judge Democrats
refused to participate in the interview
of mark judge that doesn't mean they
shouldn't publicly subpoenaed mark judge
I think that they probably should have
but it turns out that a vanadis entire
allegation from yesterday begins to fall
apart a miami-dade count the scoring
political a miami-dade County Court
docket shows a petition for injunction
against wet Nick was filed March 1st
2001 by her former boyfriend Richard
Venice II who told POLITICO the two had
dated for four years before they broke
up thirteen days later the case was
dismissed not long after an affidavit of
non ability to advance fees was filed
according to Venice II sweat Nick
threatened him after they broke up and
even after he got married to his current
wife and had a child so he says this is
a direct quote from her former boyfriend
quote I know a lot about her she's not
credible not at all didn't matter the
media repeated this stuff and I will
point out again there's some diversity
in the media you have people like Jake
Tapper who I think does try to be honest
in this is why I respect Jake and then
you have people like Don Lemon who
really does not try very hard on CNN
here's Don Lemon on CNN and saying that
Brett Kavanaugh is like Bill Cosby based
on he doesn't say right now a Supreme
Court nominee faces two allegations of
sexual assault or misconduct from his
time in high school and his time in
college back in the late 1980s Cavanaugh
denies that they ever happen when Bill
Cosby was initially accused many people
for many years could not believe it
the women's accounts were questioned
took a very long time and a lot of
investigating and multiple proceedings
before there was a verdict as to the
truth of what really happened okay so
that is not helpful at all obviously
there's no corroborating evidence but it
doesn't matter he's just like Bill Cosby
doesn't matter that Bill Cosby admitted
openly to using quaaludes humpin
Cavanaugh is exactly like that that's
not just him obviously you've got Cady
tour over at MSNBC who who did exactly
what Democrats are apt to do which is
just that anybody who doubts
corroborating evidence says that the
accusers are all liars
again I'm not claiming tempura Ramirez
is a liar I've not claimed in this
entire show that or any other show that
Christine Blasi Ford is lying I said
there's not corroborating evidence why
because facts don't care about your
feelings on this one there is no
corroborating evidence I feel terrible
for these women as well corroborating
evidence is necessary for you to buy an
account you can't just buy an account
because someone told you the account in
just a second and play what Katy tur had
to say to Cavanaugh's lawyer and then
I'm going to show you other evidence of
the media playing this as politically as
humanly possible so Jeffrey Toobin on
CNN he he is so well gets a tube in one
second first let's do Katy tur so Katy
tur was questioning Cavanaugh's lawyer
about the Deborah Ramirez allegations
and of course she doesn't ask her why do
you doubt the why do you doubt the
accusations and then the lawyer can say
listen I don't know there to doubt the
accusations or not I can tell you
there's no corroborating evidence and
instead it's why do you think she's
lying I don't have to believe somebody
is lying to suggest that their account
may be faulty I don't have to believe
that somebody is like this happens all
the time in your daily life in your
daily life with people you love they
tell you stories and you think is that
really how it went that's with people
you love and my wife is sitting behind
the camera today there are times when my
wife will tell me something that
happened and I'll say is that really how
it went and then she'll say well more
often she says this to me I'll tell her
how something which is that really what
you said and I'll think about it
tomorrow I'll say now not exactly here's
what I actually said right that sort of
thing happens all the time with people
you actually like I assume my wife likes
me but it is a truth that you in order
to have questions about somebody's
account it doesn't require you think
that they're lying per se but the media
have decided to buy into the democratic
binary either you believe the women
wholeheartedly everything they say is
verified truth without any doubts to
memory or corroborate of evidence or you
don't believe any of these women because
you think that women are liars you
believe the myth of Eve the liar
bringing the Apple to her husband you
you hate all women this is the the
narrative of the Democrats and many
members of the media been trying to
promote here's Katie towards Wayne just
that yesterday are you calling her a
liar I'm not calling her a liar I think
she has known about this for a while
supposedly and so is mr. avenatti he
waived this on some of your programs
since last weekend and said he knew
about it and he never went to the police
as an attorney I know what my obligation
is it's to my client and if I had
represented her it would have been my
duty to go to the police immediately but
this is the question right the question
is what mattered they're not the answer
the question was are you saying she's
lying if that's going to be the standard
from now on it's gonna be impossible for
anyone to escape any hearing unscathed
ever because anyone can come forward
with any allegation and then all you say
is do you believe the woman is she lying
are you saying women lie well we don't
know whether somebody is lying or
misremembering or telling the truth
unless there's actual evidence you could
have said the same thing about Toronto
Brawley you could have said the same
thing about crystal Mangum and the Duke
Lacrosse case you could have said the
same thing about Jackie from UVA you
could have said the same thing about
Emma Sokka wits at Columbia all those
women it turns out we're not telling the
truth I'm not saying any of these women
are not telling the truth I'm just
saying I don't know neither do you
were you there unless you were and if
you were you should probably come
forward and testify I think but if you
are not there you don't know you don't I
don't know either my tendency is to
believe Christine Blasi Ford's story but
I don't have enough corroborating
evidence to finish her guys career they
simply on the allegation by the way I
think there are a lot of folks on the
Democratic side who would be more honest
if they said the same thing about people
like Juanita Broderick and we're running
to Broderick accuse Bill Clinton of rape
the answer the Democrats gave was she's
not credible why what made her not
incredible what they could have easily
said is well her story is credible but
there's not enough evidence for me to
corroborate it which is the actual
objective truth about things people tell
you in real life but when it comes to
politics we all suspend this when it
comes to politics we all suspend the way
that we normally work in the realm of
the real in order to defend people we
like or to target people that we dislike
and for example here's so senator patty
Murray she comes forward and again
playing politics she says that anybody
who claims that this is a smear campaign
well that frightens me and what as a
woman well it is a smear campaign by
Democrats to bring forward a bunch of
unverified allegations with no
corroborating evidence there's no
question that is but what patty Murray
is doing is again drawing that crucial
binary Democrats know they have a
massive advantage right now with female
voters a lot of that is driven by
President Trump it really is look at the
polls from 2012 to 2016 Republican law
women in droves they've been losing
women in droves ever since Democrats
know that they can just plow a wedge
between men and women on a voting basis
if they can credibly accuse Republicans
being sexist that's the game and patty
Murray is playing it the message that
this is a smear campaign frightens me as
a woman that once again we are saying to
women out there don't come forward
you're gonna be accused of smear
campaigns no one's gonna believe you
stop do the investigation okay they are
doing an investigation and then you yell
at them for doing the investigation it's
not just remember that the worst of all
is of course Jim Acosta from CNN who's
just a garbage heap I mean Jim Acosta is
just just awful yesterday Jim Acosta
asks President Trump at his presser why
he doesn't call on a female reporter
this is just the worst kind of
grandstanding what difference does the
question make whether it comes from a
female reporter or a male reporter have
you put the exact same words in
somebody's mouth you should get the same
exact answer is my opinion cuz I treat
people as individuals according to a
cost of though Trump won't call on
female reporters cuz he's a sexist or
something if you don't mind after I'm
finished if we juror Halle or Vivian or
one of our female colleagues could go
after me that would be great
this president just to follow up on
these allegations against what happened
what does he mean by that
explain what what is what is that gonna
be I think we greater foot if a female
what does it mean what does it maybe
right if a female reporter were to ask
you a question about the this issue so
if you don't mind I wouldn't mind that
at all I wouldn't mind it at heart well
let me uh wouldn't make any difference
to me all right go ahead good for Trump
okay that's the actual correct answer
but you can see what Acosta's trying
that's reported and that so much
reporting so much journalism from Jim
Acosta who loves him some Jim Acosta
find you somebody who loves you like Jim
Acosta loves Jim Acosta my goodness but
that of course is the narrative that's
being drawn okay so how does all this
play out it probably plays out with
Kavanaugh going down it probably plays
out with Kavanaugh losing the vote or
being withdrawn and then all hell
breaking loose and Democrats proclaiming
victory and Republicans proclaiming that
they were stabbed in the back and things
just get uglier
because corroborating evidence doesn't
matter and we're not honest enough to
actually set a standard before
beforehand as to what constitutes
evidence that somebody's career should
be finished okay time for some things I
like and then some things that I hate so
things that I like I'll remind you that
when we say
all women nobody actually believes we
should believe all women nobody actually
believes that because we have to
actually look at each account on its
face we have to determine whether
somebody is telling the truth or not the
way you do this is through corroborating
evidence so I take for my example today
the movie to kill a mockingbird the book
To Kill a Mockingbird is of course one
of the great books in the English
language I think people always say
what's the great American novel to me
it's either Moby Dick or To Kill a
Mockingbird the movie of tequila
Mockingbird is it's a great movie
although Gregory Peck cannot do a
southern accent for his life but the
score is really tremendous Elmer
Bernstein's at the score just a
beautiful beautiful square used to be
the ringtone on my phone actually the
score referred to Kill a Mockingbird but
here is here's a little bit of the
preview of to kill a mockingbird and
then I will explain why this is relevant
and now happily to kill a mockingbird
becomes a motion picture and it's
memorable characters come vividly alive
that's God some people call it Jean
Louise Finch but she insists on scout
and that's her brother Jim just a boy
until the day he learns there is evil in
the world
[Music]
the score is great obviously I read Peck
won Best Actor for his performance in
this which again is weird cuz you didn't
do a southern accent but in any case the
movies great one of the reasons that I
bring up this movie is because the movie
is entirely about or at least the main
part of the movie is about an actual
false allegation of rape against a black
man by a white woman who was actually
sexually abused by her father and the
way that the accusation is overridden in
the court is not through a he-said
she-said it's through corroborate of
evidence it's through the fact that Tom
Robinson who is the black man actually
gets up and shows that he was not
physically capable of hitting this woman
on a particular side of her face because
his arm is withered from a cotton gin
accident from from his youth the point
here is that evidence still matters okay
due process still matters and whether I
believe Christine Blasi Ford or not that
is secondary to whether any standard is
necessary in order for us to destroy
somebody is any standard other than the
alligator alligator esta fine that's the
big question today that's the question
nobody's going to ask and it's the
question it's the only question that in
the end really matters for the future of
the country when it comes to nominations
due process
or any sort of trial in the court of
public opinion okay time for a quick
thing that I hate so the thing that I
hate today Don Lemon of CNN again I've
already hit Don Lemon earlier but he
really he really outdid himself
yesterday I don't know I don't know what
he was on yesterday but it was it was
solid stuff he was talking about Ted
Cruz going to a restaurant in Washington
DC and there he suggested that Ted Cruz
so what happened is Ted Cruz goes to the
restaurant a bunch of activists start
yelling its head Cruz about Cavanaugh
and he is forced to leave the restaurant
with his wife here is Don Lemon
explaining why this is totally cool I
don't like it but it is one reason I'm
not a public official that I'm not
running for office in a way I think it
goes with the territory I don't like it
they were blocking his wife but that's
what that's what he signed up for and as
a strict constitutionalist which Ted
Cruz is he knows that it's protected
under the First Amendment again why it's
not protected under the First Amendment
to go into a private establishment and
yell at people until they leave that is
not protected under the First Amendment
okay it isn't there's a lot of speech
thank God in this country that's
protected under the First Amendment
I can't enter your place of business and
just start screaming at you that is not
actually protected by the First
Amendment but Don Lemon saying that he
signed up for this yeah I'm sure he'd
feel exactly the same way if Republicans
came and yelled at Don Lemon who by the
way it's a major media figure did he
sign up for this
I don't think Don Lemon signed up for
this I don't think I signed up for this
I don't think Ted Cruz signed up for
this I don't think Trump signed up for
this I don't think Bill Clinton signed
up for this I don't think people sign up
for harassment in a law-abiding country
I don't but according to Don Lemon
apparently they do the other thing I
have to say that I hate today
jeet here is a an alleged journalist
over at the Atlantic and he tweeted this
out in the aftermath of some allegations
that were that were dumped yesterday so
Senate Republicans on the Judiciary
Committee released a Cavanaugh
investigative summary that included in
an anonymous claim of rape forward by
Kemal Harris's office that turned out to
be complete nonsense two interviews in a
written statement from a man who
believes that he not Cavanagh actually
was responsible for the assault and so
jeet here tweeted out it's incredibly
irresponsible to release this stuff a
dump of raw gossip with only the intent
of muddying the waters apparently
are illegal over at the Atlantic what do
you think the last several weeks have
been okay this is raw gossip or personal
accounts with the intent of muddying the
water hay particularly this week put
aside Blasi for two again has no
corroboration for her statements this
week we've seen several attempts at
money in the water is coming from
Michael avenatti coming from The New
Yorker all of it uncorroborated all of
it raw gossip intent at muddying the
waters but apparently it only applies to
one side of the aisle this is what's so
irritating about all this none of this
is really an attempt to get down to who
should be on the Supreme Court or
standards of proof none of this is
really an attempt to get down to even
the basic truth of what happened because
there's no way to do that without
corroborating evidence all of this is
political and anybody who tells you
difference is lying to your face and
well we will be back here tomorrow with
all of the fallout because I'm sure it
will be magnificent in its horror we'll
be back here with all of it I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wha
of era the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright Ford publishing 2018